make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with another
what if video and this time i figured
since for the last few installments of
this we've been taking things from the
dc universe and putting them in the
marvel universe that we'd change it up a
bit and so today we're going to take a
look at what would happen
if doomsday got the crimson gem of
sidorak now before we get into the story
we need to briefly
go over who doomsday is and what he's
capable of under normal circumstances
and so doomsday as you probably know is
one of superman's strongest opponents
and was famously responsible for killing
him
in the 1992 event aptly named the death
of superman now in fact doomsday was
created by dan jurgens for the specific
purpose of being a character that could
believably kill superman and so
doomsday's most notable ability is that
each time he dies he comes back to life
immune to whatever it was that killed
him he also has a healing factor that
allows him to heal from serious injuries
instantaneously
furthermore he was able to adapt
offensive capabilities based on the
weaknesses of his opponents for example
when he fought martian manhunter
doomsday developed the ability to
breathe fire because martian manhunter
had a weakness to fire while doomsday
had never displayed that ability before
of course he also possesses insane
superhuman strength which of course goes
without saying since he was able to kill
superman he also has superhuman
durability and stamina to the point of
being virtually inexhaustible now
suffice it to say doomsday is an
incredibly
powerful force even without any sort of
augmentation
and so what happens when we add the
crimson gem of sidorak to the equation
now in this case we don't really have to
stretch our story too far to figure out
how doomsday acquires the gym i mean
sidorak is an extra dimensional demon
right so it's not too far-fetched to
think that we can kind of bend the rules
a little bit and have him travel to the
dc universe
now most of you are probably familiar
with the crimson gem of sidorak as the
object that turned kane marco into the
juggernaut by imbuing him with a
fragment of sidorak's power now as a
result
juggernaut's strength and durability are
greatly enhanced he's equipped with a
force field of mystic energy and most
notably
once he gets moving it's almost
impossible to stop his momentum and in
fact as far as i'm aware of marvel
comics that's only happened once
and so if sidorak had placed the crimson
gem in the dc universe and chose
doomsday as his avatar what would happen
well simply put
doomsday would be one of the most
dangerous forces in the entire dc
universe capable of causing
a nearly unimaginable amount of damage
and so it only makes sense that he would
try and cause that damage where it would
be most likely to draw out his most
hated foe
metropolis and so as our story opens up
we basically see doomsday amped up by
the crimson gem of sidorak
laying waste to the city that superman
calls home and it doesn't take
long for the man of steel to show up and
stop the rampaging doomsday now after
taking a couple of punches however
superman quickly discovers
that doomsday is operating on a level
even beyond anything superman has ever
seen
out of him before and it's not often
that we see superman totally outclassed
in terms of brute strength but because
of the gem's power
he is completely unable to slow down
doomsday's momentum as he runs through
the streets of metropolis leveling
building
after building now superman summons all
of his strength but is absolutely no use
doomsday is simply just
too powerful and is able to defeat
superman with surprising ease
not only because of his enhanced
strength but also because the crimson
gem of sidorak is technically an object
that uses magic energy
and superman is vulnerable to magic
luckily for him before doomsday can
finish him off the rest of the justice
league shows up and engages doomsday now
seeing that superman's badly hurt
batman evacuates him from the scene and
takes him to the justice league
headquarters to recuperate
meanwhile even the combined forces of
wonder woman green lantern flash and
aquaman are having difficulty dealing
with doomsday
realizing they won't be able to defeat
him outright they devise a plan to
remove him from the area
green lantern encases him with a
hard-like construct to keep him from
polarizing her but doomsday almost
immediately breaks free of it this does
however give flash the opportunity to
travel a sufficient distance
and begin running at doomsday now
doomsday continues to run through
multiple city blocks leaving a trail of
rubble in his wake but he's eventually
hit by the flash with the infinite mass
punch
we get an epic moment of two seemingly
unstoppable forces
colliding now although the flash is
clearly capable of moving at a higher
speed than doomsday hitting him head on
proves to be a miscalculation on his
part because hitting doomsday at that
speed
is basically like running into an
immovable brick wall because its
momentum
cannot be stopped while the flash is
able to stall doomsday's movement for a
fraction of a second the collision
temporarily knocks them out cold and so
it's clear by this point that the
justice league is going to have to alter
their strategy to deal with this new
threat and most likely have to call in
reinforcements and here we get a couple
of options one strategy is to try and
bring in the physically strongest
characters they can think of or at least
ones capable of expending the most
energy in the hopes that they'll simply
be able to overwhelm doomsday and so
characters like martian manhunter
supergirl or captain adam are among our
options here on the other hand we have
characters that are adept at using magic
to try and neutralize the gem's power
as for how the justice league would know
that they need someone who can use magic
i think that once superman
recovers enough to the point that he can
talk again he'd basically be able to
sense that there's some other magic at
play
which is one of the reasons he was
defeated so handedly and so as far as
magic users there are plenty of them in
the dc universe we've got john
constantine dr
fate zatanna we really have a ton of
options here now i'm tempted to go with
shazam because he's not only a super
strong character but his powers are
rooted in magic as well but we've never
really seen him using spells which would
probably be required to neutralize the
gem of sidorak
in reality it's more of just a case of
shazam and other's powers being derived
from magic so he's probably not the best
choice we also could just call in
god-like beings like the spectre who
would probably just wipe doomsday from
existence but honestly that doesn't make
for a very interesting story
i think the best option is to have the
justice league recover from this
humiliating defeat
and find a way to defeat doomsday
themselves albeit with a little help
from zatanna and dr fate since they do
need some magical firepower
and they probably wouldn't want to
consult constantine because he's really
just a dick
now in terms of who's going to supply
the brute strength he insists that he'll
be able to be the one
to take doomsday down now as other
members of the justice league try to
talk him out of it due to his weakness
to magic he remains determined to get
back into the battle and defeat his
longtime enemy and so to this conundrum
batman offers a solution and unveils an
armor that he's developed that will not
only shield superman from the jim's
magical energy but greatly augment his
strength as well
now superman of course is hesitant in
dawning the armor as it's not something
that he does regularly but the fact that
he needs it in this situation
shows just how powerful doomsday is when
he's amped up by the crimson gym
and so the justice league converge on
doomsday who's now moved from metropolis
to gotham city
and is wreaking havoc there now at first
doomsday proves difficult for the
justice league to handle even for
superman in his magical resistant armor
and while the armor does alleviate
superman's weaknesses to magic his
strength is still proving insufficient
to stop doomsday's momentum now while it
might seem strange given how strong
superman would be in this situation
we have to remember that even when we
are dealing with kane marco as that
version of the juggernaut a character as
strong as world breaker hulk was
completely unable to stop his momentum
but instead
had to redirect it to end the fight with
him and so while we're dealing with
someone like doomsday who already
possessed strength far beyond kane
marcos he's going to be even more
unstoppable for superman wearing this
armor and so with that in mind the tide
does not turn in the battle
until zatanna and dr fate are able to
neutralize the mystical energies of the
crimson gem and so once doomsday's
connection with the gem is severed
superman is finally able to begin
dealing damage to doomsday and is also
able to endure doomsday's counter
punches thanks to the extra durability
his armor provides
and so once doomsday is sufficiently
weakened the flash would grab him and
then run a good way from the shore now
green lantern would then encase him in a
hard light box that he's unable to free
himself from
immediately due to his weakened state
aquaman would then plunge the box
containing doomsday
into the depths of the sea ridding earth
of the threat that he poses
at least for now dr fate in turn would
take the crimson gem of sidorak and
place it under a magical protection
spell within the tower of fate so that
no one could ever come into contact with
it and become the avatar of sidorak
again
and so yeah that's how i think it would
go down if doomsday got the crimson gem
of cetera
and honestly we could have gone a
different way and we could have chosen
to repeat not only the death of superman
but the entire justice league if we
wanted to go that route but let me know
in the comments and let me know what
stories you guys would like to see me
cover in the future what if episodes and
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you